[Music]
I'm just delighted to be in your
presence super nice to meet you thanks
thanks for having me yeah welcome to Los
Angeles
yeah I guess the first time yeah I know
it's right we actually having like a
really warm day finally it was pretty
cold here I mean for LA a couple days
ago really frost in the morning oh yeah
it's funny it was exciting I mean Toria
Slee don't necessarily look at the
weather yeah places I'm going I showed
up with like a down jacket and like all
kinds of warm clothes from Tahoe
well maybe last yeah that would have
been appropriate yeah yeah well yeah I
would imagine you're pretty prepared
wherever you go yeah usually for snow
maybe not fair like traffic though it's
funny I came in here earlier we were
setting up and that air conditioning was
on us like it's so cold in here it's
gonna be really cold and I was like well
first of all congratulations on being
named one of the 2018 National
Geographic what is it adventurers of the
year yeah thank you
thanks it's cool what is that yeah it
means a lot to me yeah I worked really
hard last year I kind of a crazy last
couple of years um just in my life in
general and so to really go for it last
year was a big deal for me and then to
be recognized by National Geographic for
it was pretty pretty awesome yeah it's
cool thanks and it was well first of all
I just for the listeners out there I was
super excited to also see Alex Honnold
as one of the yeah he did last year was
absolutely incredible he was he was just
in here a couple weeks ago it's pretty
awesome and also maybe even more special
was seeing Myrna Valerio Braden I don't
know much about her but I
done a little reading up on her animal
she sounds pretty incredible she's
awesome I've had her on the podcast okay
National Geographic to more right
there's five total so I'm gonna have to
track down the other two yeah no I think
there's like eight yeah there's Killian
Journey oh yeah and then this female
this surfer I'm not I don't know her
very well
yes cool so so that that was really
based on this expedition that you did
this past year I mean yes he's done like
a bazillion I can't I don't even know I
can't pronounce these names anyway but
but you know walk me through what you
did this past year that got you on that
inductee list well I have been obsessed
with this mountain in India ever since
my very first expedition that's gonna
totally date me it was like way back in
1999 a different century yeah and so in
2017 I've made one attempt on the peak
before in 2013 to no avail like we
didn't really go very far on the
mountain at all and in 2017 between 2013
and 2017 just a lot kind of went on in
my life in general and I had actually
had kind of a lot of not successful
expeditions that I'd been a part of in
fact some were like just total disasters
and I really wanted to go back to pops
aura it's called the peak of evil would
you really yeah you know something yeah
yeah I'd really it managed and the call
yeah so there was just it was just
calling me to go back and it was kind of
like I thought as this circle of life
kind of of my life and sort of a place
where I started in a place I wanted to
go back to and ultimately you know end
with some success so what is it that
that spoke to you or speaks to you about
the peak of evil like why do you why
like I'm interested in how you make the
choices that you made
like it seems like you're very
deliberate you take your time but once
you're in you're all in so what you know
how do you make that decision like why
was that one so important even though I
know you'd been there before in 2013 but
well just to give you a little
background of how I like to climb and
where I like to go in in nearly a 20
year career of expeditions I've never
been back to the same place twice I like
to I've been back to regions but never
the same mountain I really like the
adventure and the mystery and the
unknown and all that logistical planning
that goes into it but for some reason
Pop's aura just kept pulling me back in
and I think in large part when a friend
of mine first showed it to me all those
years ago it just looks so unattainable
and so beyond anything I had the skill
set for because because it was just this
massive incredibly remote peak with to
me and and I'm a skier first and a
climber second it just had this I mean I
think about the aesthetic of the peak
and the ski line on it and it just gives
me the chills and it's like this photo
just seared in my brain of this mountain
and I think back I mean I was in my
early 20s when I first saw this mountain
and was very new to the combination of
Alpine climbing and combining it was
skiing and big ski descends and it just
it just seemed like this absolutely
perfect
mountain that I would never be able to
climb mm-hmm but then flash-forward 1718
years and I just changed my skillset and
I worked really hard at learning things
and putting myself into different
difficult situations and the mountains
and just getting that skill set in
general so what is it that you had to
master to to do that one what
yeah but but I think I read maybe maybe
I'm mixing up expeditions but doesn't
this have like a 60 degree descent like
its see yeah super steep it was really
steep I was just talking about it the
other day at this sort of speaking thing
in Estes Park in Colorado and this guy
he was a climber in the back was like
well I mean you had your ice axes so you
know if you'd lost an edge couldn't you
have self arrested and basically means
if you fall on something steep you have
this really pointy sharp metal thing
that you used to like slam into the side
of the mountain so you don't slide all
the way down but the conditions were
such that there if you lost an edge
there was no way you could possibly stop
yourself and it was that steep and it
was you know kind of this hard glacial
ice with just a tiny bit you know a
couple centimeters of snow on top of it
so it was really really intense I mean I
can't say we made a lot of ski turns we
descended on our skis Wow how long did
it take you to the sand four hours to do
about 3,000 feet which if you compare
that to skiing like a powdery spine in
Alaska it might take 30 seconds you know
so a big difference in timing and just
focus and a big challenge with that face
is its there's not it's at the top of it
is over 21,000 feet mm-hmm and there's
not really a way to acclimatize once
you're on the face you start you know at
17,000 and 17,800 you have to go all the
way to the top and you can't really
climb at eyes in there so I mean you're
an endurance athlete you're so so I know
but it's like it's like you have to
train for this endurance side of things
that is really unique because it's very
slow-paced when you're at that high of
altitude but then also your
decision-making is compromised your
without the oxygen yeah but you trained
so you did this with this guy his name's
Jim Morrison yes my significant other
uh-huh yeah and you guys trained like on
Telluride like doing crazy right so I
think this this was all part of the
National Geographic recognition was that
we started by training because for me
it's not about training to be an athlete
it's training for exposure and mental
state when you're in a tough position I
bleep my whole life so yeah and sorry to
step on you
no that's okay like I'm interested in
and how you see it breaking down between
you know how much of this is mental
versus physical well I mean I this all
kind of goes into suffering it all comes
back to suffering but for me I like to
get into that space where it becomes way
more mental than physical and I only do
that through kind of intense long
endurance climbing mm-hmm
but obviously you have to have a high
physical level of training and then
combine that with the mental side of it
I mean having kids really has helped
change my mental my mental fitness but
at some point the physical fitness the
physicality of climbing only gets you so
far and what really helps me to succeed
and maybe others like like Alex Honnold
or Conrad Anker
is being able to draw physical strength
through mental toughness right and
beyond being a mother how you mean how
do you develop that for yourself I mean
is that just a matter of putting you
into those situations where you're
tested yes it is I mean it's really easy
for me to put on running shoes and go
for a run and keep that physical fitness
level ride my road bike go for a
mountain bike but to get that
exposure training you I really have to
put myself into situations where
telluride is a great place to do this
because of these crazy cool wires that
are in the mountains there I can get
into a really tight couloir that you
know rolls to 45 degrees and then you
have to pull out ropes and you know you
you can't fall you're gonna follow our
cliff you have to really like be on
every turn and that to me is where the
real training kicks in and plus you're
starting to work with all the gear you
need harnesses and ropes even way more
like articulate it's like define our
terms here
okay yeah well first of all like when
you first came across my radar I'm like
wait what like she just what like I
thought like you know climbing or
mountaineering you know alpine high
that's its own little subculture and
then you've you you're even you're into
this subculture within a scope super
keen mountaineering and I'm like what is
that where did this person come from and
how's that work you know like you're not
only ascending these insane Peaks but
you're doing it whiskey's and then
skiing back down baby yeah
so that complicates things because I
mean in some ways I like the skiing part
of it because it it keeps what you're
climbing up to a certain level because
you have to be able to ski down it so
I'm not climbing up El Cap carrying skis
or you know it has to be some sort of I
don't know mountain or objective that
while it has pretty intense Alpine
climbing side to it you still feel to
ski down it right or you know ski
descend yeah yeah how many people are in
this little world oh my gosh it's such a
small little niche yeah I mean that
backcountry skiing or side country
skiing which is when you would go up
Mammoth and you would go out a back end
off mammoth has backcountry gates but
you'd you know go into the side country
backcountry is where your
ski touring there's tons of that in the
Sierra Mountains there's tons of that
all over the US the Alps where you put
skins on your skis and you walk up
something and you ski back down ski
mountaineering I define it as something
that's more multi-day and typically
requires travel to some sort of foreign
exotic adventurous place that's not
doesn't have to be but that's ski
mountaineering and ski mountaineering to
me involves crampons which are the spiky
things on your bottom your boots and ice
axes and harnesses and there's a huge
climbing aspect to it yeah it's it's so
dynamic because you have to be you have
to be so multidisciplinary wait and
watch and it's different from Alpine
climbing in the sense that a lot of ski
mountaineering even though you're with
partners you're doing all the climbing
by soloing you're not necessarily roped
together and that was the case on pops
whare which was you know 3000 foot 50 to
60 degree basically ice face that you're
just soloing and and why do you think
you were able to master it this time
like what happened in 2013 what changed
that allowed you to conquer it well the
beauty of going back to a second place
or going back to a place a second time
is you have done all the reconnaissance
and so that was new to me and it really
just allowed me to not have to focus so
much on the logistical planning and
really just focus on the mountain and
the peak and having already seen it and
knowing what it was all about there was
a third member that went with us so we
were a team of three this time and Chris
Fagan Shaw he was with me in 2013 I made
a lot of logistical changes in that we
went later in the year so we went this
time in May instead of March and we went
with just three of us in 2013 there are
like seven of us which is just too many
for a face like that and we approach
differently so the biggest
problem in 2013 was that we only had
eyes for one particular route and after
coming home and thinking about it and
thinking how dangerous that particular
approach was I was able to look at the
face differently and realized that there
was a different approach that was much
safer and longer and better skiing
actually so those kind of changes were
made between the two expeditions and in
my first try we actually did this huge
like forty to fifty mile ski traverse at
altitude and tried to climb and this
time we just went straight in and
straight out right interesting yeah so
well congrats on that yeah thanks it's
pretty amazing and and just kind of
looking at your career I mean what
you've done I don't know 40 50 of these
yeah 40 yeah a lot of expeditions I mean
there's so many of them I had to like
make this like chichi some of the
highlights like first to Cronk climb
Everest and lotzie and yeah yeah yeah
has has anybody done that since the
first person right well first I mean
probably yeah well and with my partner
yeah in 24 hours
yeah that's yeah oh so Kilimanjaro with
a broken leg yeah that was dead and with
my kids oh my gosh and they were right
with you which we're gonna talk first
ski to sense of big Peaks in Mongolia
India Russia and Greenland yeah yeah and
and what's interesting is you're
probably best known for this epic epic
expedition in 2014 where you went to
Burma yeah
and attempted this mountain called I
watched the documentary down to nothing
which was so cool I mean the
cinematography is so extraordinary I
mean that is a story in and of itself
with Ron Austar can Cory Richards making
massive efforts and sacrifices in making
that film
so I mean let's talk about this for a
little bit I think just as a as a
preparatory comment even you know
discussing this particular expedition I
find what I find interesting about your
career is you know there's a lot of
missteps and you know quote-unquote hate
that word failure but yeah and and you
just keep going and and so I'm
interested in your relationship with
fail you're like what does that mean
what does it represent to you how does
it you know motivate you or play into
how you approach each adventure and
think about it in the aftermath well
ski mountaineering Alpine climbing I
think expeditions in general don't
typically have over the span of a career
a high percentage of success rate so I
would say I mean I'm probably pretty
50/50 on success and you know I I like
getting to the top of a mountain as
silly as energy drive you to Janice I
you know that's obviously very yeah yeah
I mean and you put so much effort like
Burma for example was two years of
planning before we actually even stepped
foot in the country and I mean I I went
to Pakistan for an 8,000 meter peak when
my first son was 10 months old and
didn't summit you know and that was like
heartbreaking to make this time away and
and not be successful so there's there's
a lot of things that I perceive as
failures but I've also had to sort of
redefine what success means to me along
the way and success in some ways is here
sitting here with you and telling
stories about these expeditions and
things that I've learned about human
nature and interpersonal relationships
and banging your head against a wall
sometimes and overcoming failure is
become sort of I guess my success story
and
weird twisted way so if you had to
distill down those lessons and I know
you get up in front of people all the
time yeah talk tonight you know what is
that message that you're trying to
convey when you tell these stories I
think it's truly truly a necessity to
have a passion as a compass in life but
to have a passion on some levels really
sucks and it's hard and if it's worth it
you're gonna fall on your face several
times on your way to like sort of
reaching the goal that is the
fulfillment of this passion and I've
done it epically on many levels but I I
think happiness is not a great word to
use I don't like that word I think just
in search of happiness or fulfillment or
just a deeper understanding of my own
self and how I can inspire people has
been really the culmination of those
times falling on my face writing that
passion so yeah so so in other words
like passion is you know has its has its
beauty and yeah it's dark side that has
a really dark side to say you know it's
a close bedfellow of obsession are
familiar with fine line me too
and the pursuit of of that passion or
the following of that obsession in your
case involves you know suffering and
also elation mate but suffering is
unavoidable and in fact suffering is a
key component to connecting with
yourself in that way like on that path
to like you know really trying to
understand what makes you tick so that
you can come back
more fulfilled with something to say
right yeah and I mean I think I think it
comes down to how if you don't have
suffering in your life how do you
experience the opposite how do you
understand what elysion is what
fulfillment is if you don't experience
the opposite and if you haven't had
major failures in your life and been
able to make something of them turn them
into something you've learned from them
how do you appreciate the successes that
you have in life yeah it's all connected
it is it is and I think well a couple
observations you know most people maybe
not most people but there's a lot of
people who who don't have that TrueNorth
that don't have a passion or they don't
know what it feels like to have some
form of healthy obsession the way it
propels them forward you know and that
combined with a culture that emphasizes
you know security and safety and luxury
and comfort at the you know at the
forsaking of suffering creates a
population of people who are not
connected in the way that you're
intimately familiar with right so I
would imagine when you go and you speak
you probably meet a lot of people that
might say something along those lines to
you like I don't know you know how does
that feel to be that way how do I find
my passion right I you definitely get a
lot of questions of like what drives you
what makes you go back to to continue
doing this and I don't know infusion
yeah y-yeah and you know there's been
plenty of times in my life when I'm and
take peak of evil for instance when I
like wake up in the middle of the night
obsessing you know this crazy dream that
I'm back on that mountain and I have to
go back and I mean believe me I just
wish it would go away sometimes and I
could just be content with being
comfortable and having showers and
right almost like you have no free will
[Music]
yeah something yeah it's wild it's cool
I mean look you know the subject of I
mean suffering is something I you know
appreciate yeah understand the value of
and I've had plenty of guests and lots
of your North Face teammates may notice
that across from me and I you know I'm
remembering Dean Karnazes speaking
eloquently about you know the importance
of suffering in his life as it really as
a tool as a vehicle to you know to that
deepening that quickening of connection
with self that allows you to really
understand what makes you tick and be a
fully integrated person Bay Bay and so
whether it's running or climbing or
whatever you are you're driving
Northstar yeah maybe it's music maybe
it's your job or your family whatever it
is you have to work hard for it
something you just have to work hard for
and and and stop looking for the
shortcut but actually embrace that
difficult journey ahead right yeah yeah
I just popped into my mind that movie
whiplash do you see that movie about the
drummer yeah yeah so yeah I guess
example it's just a different context
right it's kind of that same message
yeah suffering and enduring discomfort
and I mean then I've said this a bunch
of times like one of my biggest fears in
life is getting is just being too
comfortable and you know having every
day be the same and I think I go to
sometimes unhealthy extremes to keep
that from coming too
haha yeah so let me throw a word at you
and and and if you could respond what
what comes to mind when I say balance I
mean the first thing I get asked a lot
like how do you balance it all and I I
don't to me balance as a moving target I
think it's this sort of ever morphing
thing that I strive for how do i balance
being a mom doing these expeditions I I
find myself compartmentalizing a lot and
I don't I just I don't have a lot of
balance in my life well I think I think
you know I think we're we've become
confused about this subject matter of
like how do you how do you live a
balanced life or how do you find balance
it's more for me like reconciling like
my love for the suffering and all these
other things that other people think is
out of balance like that's my
equilibrium point like the pendulum is
swinging you know yeah it always has to
come back to the center like you figured
way of looking at it actually
ya know too late that you're it's just
if you look at your the way I described
it for myself and and maybe you'll
relate to this is like if you look at
your life over a one-year or two-year
three-year period like it probably looks
balanced the time with your kid whatever
you write it's not gonna look like
somebody else's life but yeah it's not
balance to like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
you know my kids are gonna stay at home
I'm gonna go to Pakistan yeah yeah yeah
that's that's not balance in the
traditional sense but that's something
that you are compelled to do in order
for you to find your own equanimity
right right
basics yeah when I look at my life over
a longer stretch of time I see the
balance in that length of time when I
look at ya and the macro
look at it in this micro picture to me
it's you know there's a lot of highs and
lows and there's there's you know just
swinging back and forth and craziness
and I think I think climbing an
expedition life in general lends itself
to crazy emotional swings where you're
and and as an athlete yourself I'm sure
you can relate to this you you have
these goals and you focus so hard within
the moment to attain these goals and
then when you get there it's kind of
like there's this crazy letdown on some
level and so emotionally you're kind of
this this up-and-down yo-yo effect but
yeah over time in the macro picture it's
it's smooth is out it normalizes it
balances itself
I like how I cracked up when I saw this
that like you're trying to sort of in an
effort to kind of maybe normalize a
little bit your life I need to be home a
little bit more so rather than go out on
three or four expeditions of you I'm
going to do one and I'm gonna do an
Ironman more time with my kids like for
you that's like really like shrinking it
down yeah manageable task yeah that was
my teeth that was my 2016 I know I
didn't go on a single expedition but I
how'd the Ironman go I did an Ironman
what did you do it was in North Carolina
and it was a new one and I don't know if
they did it again but they cut the bike
ride in half because they just gotten
that big hurricane and so I got a little
chip so now I go that now I'm like
alright let's talk about the mean look
there's so many like interesting aspects
to this expedition but but you know I
think one of the things that made it
super unique is well you I want you to
describe it but you had this like 30-day
Trek you know through
you know the jungle just to get to like
the base camp
yeah and that was like you know before
you even start actually ascending this
incredible mountain yeah geyser just
have already met and faced and had to
overcome like a bazillion unforeseen
obstacles right it's crazy right just
like helicopter into base camp and was
the premise behind that expedition like
the majority of us had just come off of
the Mount Everest climb a few years
before and we were really like trying to
do something very anti everest in the
sense of just complete unknown adventure
and that involved traveling Overland so
there really first of all there isn't
really an option to fly in with a
helicopter it's just doesn't happen
there and it's super sketchy and I
wouldn't want to be in a helicopter that
would fly that far north in that
particular country in that region right
so we're in Burma so we're in Burma the
same thing right
Myanmar yes so right before we went in
Obama officially as the United States
recognized the new name and started
calling it me environment so we you know
in the film I think we refer to it as
Myanmar but yeah Burma Myanmar and I go
back and forth then how I use it cuz
it's still the Burmese people that live
in Myanmar but um we ended up I mean me
and Mars a unique place to begin with
had been closed off for decades to
Westerners most definitely in that very
northern region and something a lot of
people don't know I didn't really even
realize this is that it's the Himalayas
that drop down into the northern part of
Burma and that's where we were headed so
it's the very eastern tail of the
Himalayas that end in Burma and so the
idea was you're gonna chart this
mountain it's never been ascended and no
one really knows exactly how high it is
right so you're gonna get an IPS reading
on it and
official right so we did been climbed
once in 1996 by this Japanese man who
had subsequently been killed on Everest
a few years later and he was a famous
you know Japanese climber I'm totally
spacing his name right now of course
because I whatever but he described it
as the most difficult mountain he ever
been on or near and he he made it to the
top on his third climb his third attempt
and didn't have any jungle thing he did
the juggled jungle trek multiple times
and but that was 20 years yeah
prior to our trip so and no one had
really been in there since then so it
was just an adventure and we went
overland from being gone which is over a
thousand miles south of the mountain and
walked a hundred and fifty miles through
the jungle over two weeks right yeah
yeah it was like day thirty day 30 when
we got to base camp from the day we left
the United States to base camp was 30
days and what was cold the movie is
there's little dials like odometers yeah
your food you know yeah you have and you
could see it like oh man yeah it's gonna
be a problem
yeah and that was the biggest problem
was running out of food and they were
just you know unforeseen things like
getting bribed out of our rice reserves
by the sort of military outposts and
some of these remote villages and unless
your gas didn't work right or something
like that yeah and we you know my my
history and planning expeditions is
doing it in Nepal in India and even
Pakistan where they have a huge history
of climbers coming to their mountains
and that history just doesn't exist that
infrastructure for climbers is
non-existent in Burma and so finding
porters to carry help carry our loads
back to this incredibly technical peak
and having enough food to get us back
there like it's you know we needed 80
Porter's yeah we had about 25 or
thirty so we had to cut our gear by
two-thirds just you know it was just it
was epic yeah well I think I've heard
you say this before like like that's
adventure adventure is right is
adventure begins when things start going
wrong right right yeah all goes smooth
then how much of an adventure was it
real
right I mean and the irony is that you
know yeah we spent two years planning
this trip and then you get there and
everything you planned just kind of goes
out the window and but you know you have
to take time to get permits and just
just legal logistical things and then
once you're actually there and the
immigration officers are stopping you in
the airport and telling you that you're
all these permits you work so hard to
get or no good and you can't get on the
plane and you can't get I mean it was
just one thing after another but yeah
should I throw down some some dollars
here and there's no like you were like
trying to figure this out on Google Maps
right there's no like route maps or
anything there's no route maps there's
no information on the peak whatsoever
and Google only can take you so far and
you know of course like a lot of 90% of
the technical part of the climb on
Google Maps when you look at the imagery
is all like blurred out so you can't
really tell what you're up against and
yeah I mean it was on one hand it was
totally awesome yeah I mean it was
exactly what we were looking for we just
forgot to remind ourselves of that when
we were in it mm-hmm and this was a
National Geographic like sponsored
expedition and yeah you were the team
leader there were five of you there was
one other woman yeah and there's been
you know there's sort of this widely you
know documented publicized rift that
took place when it came to who was gonna
make the final push up to the summit
right and that was you know in the movie
it kind of just glossed over that
backpacks great it didn't make a big
deal of that but certainly been a lot
written about that and
you know kind of outspoken about not
being one of those people and and I
think it it's a if you're willing to
talk about it you know in light of kind
of you know we're having a cultural
moment right now yeah empower the male
team healthy you know this is your this
is your time Hillary yes is an amazing
moment right now and as somebody who is
you know a phenomenal female role model
and you know an embodiment of female
empowerment can you walk me through like
what happened and and kind of how you I
mean that was this was a couple years
ago now how you know your perspective on
it now and in light of kind of what's
happening at the moment right so it this
has always been a hard thing for the
last few years for me to really talk
about in a clear succinct way there like
so many things in life there were so
many complicating factors and
contributing personalities contributing
histories that made this situation so
unique and so difficult I have been
climbing and skiing mountains for like I
said a really long time and I've never
experienced this type of team dynamic
before and I think you know whether or
not I should have been on the three out
of the five of us to go to the summit I
should have been included in the
conversation and that's where things
really went south but if I can paint you
a picture of where we were you know we
left base camp with really like eight
days of food to go off into more
absolutely unknown terrain we made it up
to this high ridge at about 18,000 feet
and it's incredibly exposed so maybe
it's only eight feet wide at most and 50
feet long and it just drops off into
sheer cliffs all all around it so the
wind was blowing you know gusting 50 60
miles an hour and we're trying to have
these conversations and figure out how
we're going to go forward and
the stress we were already you know
fairly starving we already felt like we
just skirted death several times just
even getting to base camp and there were
you know really I conceived of this trip
with a co-leader on the expedition mark
Jenkins and he was a writer for National
Geographic and has done tons of
expeditions himself and as a writer to
said and what happened was basically the
disintegration of our relationship as
climbing partners on this expedition and
I think my naivete if you will was that
I thought the trip was about the two of
us climbing and to me sometimes that's
more important than really reaching the
summit it's really just maintaining that
partnership in that interpersonal
relationship and Mark had this whole
back history going on of where he'd been
there to try this mountain before with
his two best friends who in the
intervening years had both been killed
in climbing accidents and I think his
vision was that he was going to climb
with Renan and Cory and sort of reenact
this moment that he wanted to relive to
honor his best friends right and I knew
nothing about that and so he just sort
of manipulated the situation to where he
was climbing with Korey and Rijn on and
just completely caught Emily and I out
of the equation
Emily admittedly was emily harrington
who's an incredible climber i mean she
kind of said like i'm done i'm good she
was done she was pushed to her point but
in no small part because of the the
pressures from the rest of the team put
on her but it was this was new train for
her so her stepping out of it was
totally understandable and and the right
thing and i think it was just the way it
came across at high camp where i found
myself in this position of like toll
shocked and like what are you guys
talking about like what do you mean I'm
not part of this climb to the summit
like I know how to climb and my climbing
came into question and it was just
really an awful uncomfortable situation
and sent me into quite a tailspin four
months after the expedition of it was
this a female thing because as a female
and a mostly male climbing world
I am constantly feeling like I have to
prove myself and you know at some point
when I've been doing this long enough
it's like alright I am Who I am I am
what I am my National Geographic
adventure of the year right anybody but
I can imagine you know how challenge I'm
you know I can barely imagine like how
challenging that must have been so these
three guys go off they make the push
they ultimately have to retreat right
and then you've got like the movie just
kind of you know suddenly you know
flash-forward you guys are home
basically right you're gonna go you do
that hike again yeah we had to hike all
that way out not sure you know sir
there's no unity amongst the group
anymore did you have to repair that to
make it home yeah we did we did repair
it and to some extent for sure with
Korey and Renan and Cory Richards who's
ending one of the most incredible
photographers I've ever been able to
work with and he's a National Geographic
photographer and he just has incredible
raw talent but he's also a very
temperamental person he is incredibly
confrontational and we've done stuff
together and we have these this
interaction where we can like growl at
each other and fight and then we get
over it and we talk about it we work
through it we move on and that is
exactly what happened with Burma and
Renan is quite different in that he's
very stoic he's he's quiet he he doesn't
go you know deep into conversation about
these things but
you know that's just his way of dealing
with a situation but we you know talked
quite a bit as well on the way out and
really it was just mark you really dug
his heels in about both Emily and I and
not considering our skills to be up to
par there was I don't know if you read
some of marks blogs yeah but I heard
there was really vilified March that
were made and then you you were placed
in a position of having to respond to
that yeah yeah you guys like are you
good now or is that just no not really
with and I'm okay no no we're not and I
are great and Cory and I are great and
same with Emily but mark just he said
he's you know he beats to his own drum
to begin with and I am old enough in my
wise enough if I could use that word to
just not need to repair certain
relationships and to be okay with that -
yeah well let's let's uh let's take it
back a little bit okay I mean I wanted
to talk about that and I appreciate your
being open in order to really kind of
understand your career and what makes
you tick I think we really have to
understand your background your
childhood a little bit you know you grew
up in a very interesting you know
adventure some type of family situation
yeah going these crazy boat trips and
right but it wasn't like you were that
little kid skier from day one like you
were playing all kinds of sports right
back grew up in Seattle I grew up in
Seattle and I kind of had this same sort
of life that I see myself and now only
mine's a little more extreme but we're
the very like normal mom stayed at home
dad went to work
I played traditional sport so did my
brother and sister lived in the suburbs
and in the summers we would get on this
old wooden
chris-craft bowed and then go off and
have these crazy adventures up in the
inside passage in Canada and you know be
on the boat for weeks on end you know
sometimes you know the whole summer you
name it and this is before cellphones
and just like that so yeah I mean that
the freedom and the kind of I don't know
openness yeah I would imagine kind of
informed your path on some level for
right I mean I the way I kind of look at
it is that had this these really too
strong influences and one is that
structure of team sports and for me it
was basketball which was the main one
and and then I had this freedom and this
wild side where as like a five year old
I'm running my own boat and you know and
like black waters of Canada and on these
beaches and there's bears and fishing
and all of that and kind of pairing
those two sides to me is very sort of
mirrors where I'm at now where I have
this home life and kids and and then I
go off on these big expeditions and kind
of how how a lot of times I feel like
I'm two different people yeah it sounds
like dad was kind of intense my dad he
was like the guy at the soccer games or
the basketball games yeah yeah that guy
yeah I can't I mean there are countless
games that basketball games and he just
got straight-up thrown out of the gym
and you know he he was my coach so
basically I played basketball with the
same group of women from the time I was
seven years old to 18 years old so and
he wanted you to hear like a college
basketball player he wanted me to be a
college basketball player and he was
very much I mean he still watches the
video tapes of my basketball games and
still is like I can't believe you missed
that shot are you serious yes yes yeah
so so that's I mean look that's head
right heavy yeah when you're in it when
you're a kid you don't know any
different but like right you don't know
any different intense situations so and
he was really intense with my brother
and my sister and where are you in the
pecking order of your siblings I am the
youngest yes oh wow
so he maintained that and did he was he
throwing down on the on your brothers
and sisters too or yeah much more so
than me I think I got the not too much
no well and I also learned how to like
kind of duck and dive I was pretty good
at it so but with that comes generally
you know that sort of mean you want that
approval right like you're right yeah
you know if he's like hey you should
done this done that like yeah yeah and
that's funny yeah I mean I of course
then ultimately went down a path that he
doesn't an athletic path but he doesn't
understand or relate to and and to his
credit he supported me the whole way and
has done you know a lot of effort trying
to understand it a little bit better and
you know would pull along the way of
being like when are you gonna get a real
job when are you gonna stop doing this
and I think in large part because what I
do scares my parents yeah
but it doesn't even kick in until you're
at Colorado College right right yeah
yeah so I mean were you gonna play
basketball Colorado College or you just
decide you weren't gonna be a basketball
player what well I decided I wasn't
gonna be a basketball player I have a
different plan hehe went out just
Colorado College doesn't have like a
right a major not that kind of place so
he came out with me like that
orientation week and you know and I'd
already told him I wasn't gonna play
basketball and I very much remember him
being like oh you know I just want it
let's go let's just go look at the gym
and have a team though they have a team
and he'd actually secretly set up this
meeting with the coach telling her that
I wanted to play and oh my gosh it
resulted and probably one of the biggest
fights I've ever had
my dad but it also ping ponged me like
off the sidelines and away from the yeah
yeah I was like I think I'm like why is
he wired like that I you know he did I
think it was a part of his kid's life
that he could tangibly have an effect on
and be present for and he didn't have
that in his own life growing up and so
he really went deep with it and I you
know I learned a lot from him and some
of it is the opposite of probably how he
meant for me to absorb what he was but
the drive the ability to like really
like prepare like all of that like
diligence I would imagine you know in
some respects yes is driven by you know
kind of growing up underneath his
umbrella yeah yeah I would say yeah all
right so you're a Colorado ecology of
the blowout you figure out like Oh
skiing is pretty good here and there's
lots of cool mountains yeah you just get
into it that's where it kind of begins I
mean I luckily like first week of going
to Colorado College I kind of fell in
with this group of friends that were
rock climbers and backcountry skiers and
just way more into that adventure side
of things that I didn't know anything
about I mean I grew up in Seattle
Washington where most Mountaineers like
go to be Mountaineers and I left Seattle
to learn how to be a mountaineer so it
was really just about who I started
connecting with and and that school in
particular really encourages sort of
these alternative sports and adventures
and well have that cool thing where you
you just do one class yes for like I
don't know a month and then yeah you get
like a week off yeah and so we'd have
these block breaks where we'd go to Red
Rocks in Nevada and do these huge climbs
or you know you're surrounded by
Colorado 14 Aires and I started like
climbing up mountains to ski down them
and
had never used my athleticism in that
way and I would never say that I am like
this incredible downhill skier I'm
really good at it but I'm not ingrid
backstrom
or I'm not like a Lindsey Vonn by any
stretch of the imagination but I put
those together and it's like this
magical thing right so so when you first
tap into this is there like a
knowingness like oh this is my this is
gonna be my thing or was it just a
gradual like that like this I want to do
a little bit more and it just kind of
evolved or yeah it was pretty gradual
for me it was gradual I just the more
because I mean you have to understand I
knew absolutely nothing about it I
didn't even know rock climbing existed
until I was 19 and went to the Garden of
the Gods the first time and was like
whoa ropes and harnesses and what is all
this and I I mean I just I loved it
right so you decided to go to shaman II
yeah that was right I was just gonna go
for a few months yeah and then you
wherever like five or six years I was
there for a really long time that's my
kind of the mecca right this is where
all these was yeah it was the mecca and
I went there really because of the
downhill skiing that I'd seen in like
all the ski movies of that era the
blizzard of Oz it's so on and so forth
and ended up realizing what a huge
component climbing is to the skiing that
takes place in Gemini and that was when
I started getting into ice axes and
crampons and all that technical side
that goes with right ice and snow and
glaciers and all of that and was there a
thing at that time called like ski
mountaineering or were you I mean was
there was a community there right but
was there a community in that specific
discipline or does that just go with
like hey if you're gonna ski you gotta
like hike with this stuff I think it was
more of the ladders like hey if you're
gonna ski you have to take because there
lift access is so integrated with
climbing mountains and skiing so it's
all--it's it was before we had sort of
access off of our own ski areas in the
United States everything was really
bound read in the US at that point so
and it's not so much anymore but in
Germany you could get off a lift and go
anywhere you wanted I mean I remember
the statistic when I first moved there
that on average one person a day died in
the Shama new valley one a day and it
was just from falling ice wingsuits for
wingsuits and all of that so I'm sure
the number and and yeah BASE jumping and
whining yeah everything so it was also
my introduction to the pitfalls of this
thing that I love so much and you know
starting to see people closer and closer
to me dying in the mountains and what
that meant and processing that and that
eventually was the reason I left chemin
E was because I was becoming very
flippant and unemotional towards death
and I didn't think that was okay it was
really scary was there was there a
moment like how many people that you
knew passed away during that period of
time Oh a lot yeah a lot I mean and
you're 23 years yeah 23 yeah Wow
24 yeah I think I left there by the time
I was 28 just knows a lot just you just
start to normalize that yeah and you
start to really normalize it and yeah
it's just not okay just gonna be a man
you'll like less precious about your own
life though because you see it so much
and does I mean how did that impact how
you assess risk at that time I don't
think I was good at assessing risk at
that time I think I just didn't know
enough I mean I really and I've said
this before it's a miracle I survived
that first winter and Shama knee because
I just was
blindly following woohoo and let's go
this way and so it was a wicked steep
learning curve at first and I mean I
like I was like flying tandem off the
North Face of the agui de MIDI in my
first couple of weeks being there and
not knowing what you're doing I think it
was 96 when you won like the extreme
skiing right you know in the playing
field was like me and two other women
right so what's really new you've done
that right like what I would have
thought like whoa oh well this is
obviously my thing
right but at the same time I was also
doing these touring combo Ski
competitions where you're you're almost
like they're called Rando races now what
you're kind of ski touring through the
peaks and then you rip the skins off and
you ski something and I was doing really
well in those and I just found sort of
more satisfaction I'm not somebody who
really likes to jump off cliffs and
stuff and that was more the extreme
comps and and it's it's a distinction
between competition and pure adventure
for sure right yeah alright so then then
everything kind of changes when North
Face enters the equation right which is
sort of tailored right in the middle of
them yeah it's like well know kind of
the tail end yeah it was in 99 so I'd
been there three years it was a little
yeah towards the tail in and they're
like hey we want to pay you and you can
go do all this yeah I can have this as a
career and get paid to do what I'm gonna
be doing anyway like that's crazy like
did that did it strike you before that
like oh I can have a career doing this I
mean no not really I mean I thought I
could I at the time in Germany I was
doing great at making enough money to
perpetuate staying there so I was you
know winning money from competitions I
was doing some really cheesy ski
modeling and like you know Bognor one
teachers
yeah and then and then I kind of got on
the map with North base through a friend
who was an athlete with them at the time
and he sort of bridged that connection
which is how a lot of paths get taken I
think in life is just connections and
timing and three weeks later I was on an
expedition in India which was where I
saw pops Tora
the peak of evil would bring it all full
circle and I mean that that's why I'm
like high-altitude and winter camping
and heavy packs and I just loved it I
don't know it was I think a big part to
was like this wide-eyed girl who'd
hardly traveled it in her whole life and
going to India and this culture and the
craziness and madness of India was just
really eye-opening for me and now having
visited all these amazing places over
the years like what do you take away
from being immersed in these various
cultures like how does that impact you
in terms of how you perceive life here
in America like is it does it change or
shift your value set at all most
definitely I I talk about this a lot
with my kids even trying to explain like
mom's reentry into the United States of
America and what that means and I have a
hard time with it I think that some of
the systems we have in place in this
country are detrimental to the soul of
us as human beings we create too much
culture no we're not the happiest
culture and I think that's the thing
that stuck with me the most from my very
first trip to India was going through
seeing real poverty for the first time
and shacks and shanties and
kids with no shoes and dirty clothes and
you know families living in a hundred
square foot hovel basically and what
really struck me was the smiles on these
kids faces and the closeness of the
family unit and the brightness in their
eyes to me looked like happiness in a
form I had never seen it before
mm-hmm and in a place I couldn't even
conceive of and how do you reconcile
that with what we as Americans consider
happiness of like the new car and the
big house and the white picket fence and
possession the latest phone right and so
how do you reconcile that as a mother
with two boys there what like ten and
eight or something like yeah ten innate
you know it's I like to I have I've
taken my kids to Nepal I've taken them
to different places and I hope to
continue doing that and just you know we
live in a very fairly
utopic town Telluride Colorado and it's
an amazing place an incredible community
for kids to grow up in but they need to
see and experience cultures outside of
that particular culture and outside of
the United States because I I don't
think our way is the end-all answer you
know to fulfilling life and it's sort of
your answer to or your version of these
five week boat trips that you went on as
a kid right yeah it's your way of
providing that for your boys yeah that
adventure that unknown risk-taking fear
I mean I remember distinctly and Nepal
coming into this village
right at the time when all the kids were
getting out of school you know and
they're all different ages and my kids
eyes are just like oh my gosh they've
never seen anything like this and they
proceeded to spend like four hours
playing tag with 50 kids from this
village and none of them could
communicate but they're just oh my god
they had the best time ever and running
around and just getting dirty and you
know watching our dinner which was you
know this local goat get slaughtered and
cut up and put on the table and just it
was really I mean they talked about it a
lot still just like remember those kids
and how you know it was made a huge
impression on them and I guess that is
somehow how I reconcile it it's often
it's really hard for me if you can
imagine being on an expedition like
Burma for example where you are just out
there for weeks and weeks on end and
then you come back to mirrors where you
can see yourself I mean I didn't have a
shower for over a month and running
water and these these little things that
come back into your world slowly and you
just have this recognition of them and
this appreciation of it and of course
you know then you're back in the States
and six months later you forget about it
but at the time it's really it takes
hotel and having a huge buffet of food
and we'd been living off of white rice
three meal two meals a day for two weeks
and I couldn't I couldn't engage I
couldn't I just wanted more white rice I
didn't know how to engage back into that
world it's like the the homeless person
that you provide a bed and then they end
up sleeping on the floor right and yeah
there's an acclamation period that's to
take place it's interesting as a mom you
know what what sort of sets you apart
from your fellow climbers beyond the
fact that you've
these extraordinary things and your
woman is that you are a mom right and so
that it makes it heightened you know
when you decide like okay I'm gonna do
this expedition I mean I already did an
expedition when your your boy was ten
months old right and so that's a very I
would imagine a difficult decision to
make and I would imagine also plays into
how you assess risk now right so how
does that work for you like it kind of
goes back to the balance question right
like yeah like this is who you are like
to repress that because you're a mom
that would be to kind of contravene your
blueprint right so to speak yet it's
undeniable that you know children need
their mother and obviously you don't
want to go take undue risk so how does
that like interplay it's very
complicated it sounds like to figure
that out right I mean that particular
time in my life that particular
expedition I mean I was a complete crazy
person on that trip to Pakistan but I
was so so terrified of not picking up
that part of my life and I think part of
that goes back to my own childhood again
and having an amazing mom who stayed at
home and drove us drove me to all his
basketball games all over the place and
but also had this huge she didn't have
her own identity in the sense that once
we were all gone she you know she had a
really hard time and she talked about a
lot of her regrets you know I was the
youngest child so I basically spent my
whole high school home you know as the
only kid and it was hard for and that
really left an impression on me of like
oh my god I have to keep my own identity
I have to keep my own identity yeah into
the family I wasn't able to express
herself yeah and just yeah and just
always talking about all these things
she wanted to do but was never I mean
she came from
you know small family that lived on
Orcas Island with like five kids in our
high school and so in her trajectory of
life she made a lot of changes and did a
lot of crazy adventures but just very
different and it just stuck with me that
I had to keep this identity I had to
keep myself because I thought that would
be a better way to be a better mom and
to have my kids see me as a as a person
uh-huh
and and they're probably old enough now
where they can understand what it is
that you do yeah like what is it what do
they think what do they say I mean they
think it's great you know someone asked
me the other day if my kids have ever
asked me to stop and stay home don't
just stay home don't go mom and no you
know they never have like this is the
way they are in our family and in my
life it's normal to them what I do and
they love it and they think it's great
you know and I try to like incorporate
it by going to their schools and talking
about things and you know they've
they've been to some of these national
geographic live shows and they get I
mean they you know they hiked into
Makalu base camp with me and instead you
know they get out the globe and they're
like we want to go here next we want to
see this or I have a friend at school
it's from Australia when can we go there
and so they have a almost the opposite
reaction versus you know no mom don't go
they it's like when we want to go with
you where are we gonna go so but I
didn't know that at the time like I
didn't know how following this path as a
mother and when my kids were young I
didn't know how it was gonna turn out
and it was pretty terrifying for me I
was like what you know what if I'm doing
permanent damage to my kids or they hate
me or you know I mean I think every
parent has that fear every firm
yeah and you know whatever whatever
we're doing we're making mistake we're
all making mistakes yeah like nobody's
doing this perfectly but I think just
the fact that you have that impulse
means you're conscious of that that
you're aware of that which probably
means that you're good it's the person
who doesn't think about that kind of
thing that yeah I would worry about but
I think what's interesting about that
what you just said is you know a
conservative traditionalists perspective
would be look you know you've had your
good times already it's time to like be
a mom you can't do all those crazy
things you know that your prior you got
to do pump up whatever but I think the
alternative perspective and the
perspective that I would share an offer
is that there's something incredibly
powerful and empowering about a parental
figure or anyone for that matter who is
so whose whose life is so consistent
with their Dharma like you are you are
being who you are right unapologetically
in a very fierce and give me a long time
to get to that for sure yeah okay like
but but that is a powerful example for a
child to see hey my mom's a badass like
she all these people are telling her you
shouldn't do this shouldn't do that and
she does it anyway and she kicks ass and
and she she's not gonna apologize for
who she is you know and there's
something like so so life-affirming
about that you know that yeah and and
you know even at a young age like they
get that you know they get that like
you've met obstacles you've overcome
them or or even when you know you don't
reach these you don't reach the peaks of
the eat whatever you tried you know you
get yourself out there and I think as
much as anything that is a message that
is important for kids to see like to say
yeah I I have this other thing I want to
do and like if she can go and do that
then like maybe I can go and do this
right right whatever that is it will be
you know different from you but I think
that you know we'd probably be better
off with more more people who you know
lived boldly in that work
and of course it comes with its risks
right yeah but what would you do if one
of your kids was like I just want to
play video games now it's like you go
Burma no like I'm staying here and I'm
gonna be a video game guy like if it was
just you know it's like that right it's
like I mean I love there don't like your
kids are the greatest teachers right
yeah it's like oh my kids are gonna be
they're gonna love the things that I
love and Yabba tably it's not it's it's
wired to not be that way so that you
have that tension right and then you'd
be learned from that right and I see
that even in my own childhood and
growing up and I saw you with your dad
right yeah all right you REBOUND a
different directions and I mean I that
is the point of a parent you live in is
like I don't want to ski I don't know
whatever I mean unfortunately
fortunately like I have plenty of
friends and Telluride whose kids are
like that and you know it takes some
getting used to but you know they're
interested in other things and again I
just it makes me go back to hopefully
it's not video games but like I want my
kids just to be passionate about
something you know about something just
to have some emotional attachment that
give them a north as you said gives them
that is a compass in their life gives
them something to wake up in the morning
for and hopefully because what I know
what that compass is for me is just
wilderness and snow you know hopefully I
would love it if that was a part of
their life but it doesn't need to be all
of their life but you know right well
well maybe that's some some growth like
you're not gonna be your dad right right
yeah and they're not going to be me and
they're not gonna know their dad right
well more will be revealed I suppose
right I suppose I mean you have kids to
like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and it's like you know they they
you think it's gonna be one way and then
it's a different yeah and it's like how
do you flow with that and write how do
you love and support them when they have
interests that are thin things that like
you wouldn't be interested yeah you know
what I mean like this that's all part of
it and in some ways it's been really I
mean I think it's one of the most
amazing aspects of being a parent is
having these little minds that see
things for the first time and remind me
to not be so jaded and to to see things
through their eyes and it sounds totally
cliche but it is it's a that's the
amazing part about being a parent it's
like oh yeah like it this is an amazing
thing like and notice the little things
that affect their day or make them happy
you know that it's - I have a friend Rob
Bell and he says that you know we all
need to live our lives with a little bit
more awe and Wonder right and kids wake
up in the morning with awe and Wonder
and we we lose it yeah and you know
living an adventurous life like you do
there's a lot of oh yeah I think that's
as much of what I'm passionate about is
anything what do you think people don't
understand about what you do like if if
people have some misapprehension or they
don't really get like what is this ski
mountaineering thing like what is it
what is it that you wish they understood
that you understand about it or that
venture in general I mean I think I
would like people to understand that
there there's so much more to it than
the summit at the end of the day the
most I've taken what this adventuring
has given me is a capacity to be present
I wish I could take that ability to be
present into my day-to-day life at home
but it's just really hard for me
but on an expedition and when you're in
these intense situations you're really
like focused on one step in front of the
other your whole world is about shelter
water food survival and it's this
incredibly simplistic and powerful
experience that we've gotten so far away
from and really that is what keeps me
going back and keep on keeps me wanting
to have these new adventures and then of
course there's just you know that that
all that path along the way of you know
take one expedition I did to the Isle of
South Georgia where it's where
Shackleton was finally rescued and he
and on that in order to get from the
boat to the mountains you had to walk
through three hundred thousand penguins
and elephant seals and half the time
we'd never even get to the mountain
because we just stop and sit down and
hang out with this crazy wildlife scene
that would unfold in front of us and
like that's the stuff I take away from
it is having those experiences yeah so
when you think back on like Burma it's
probably not you know like the the last
day before you retreated it's somewhere
along the trail when the motorcycle
wiped out or you know yeah it's yeah
it's the journey and the obstacles faced
that give it value for you yeah and and
the thing about Burma is it is it's the
human dynamic as well getting to know
myself you get to know other people
really quickly but I wasn't like I saw
the worse side of myself on that trip as
well and I saw you know really where
sides of we all it was so raw and we
were so strung out that we all lost it
at one point or another and the beauty
of it was that if somebody lost it the
rest would kind of come in to rally and
pick up the slack and
and as a unit we were able to all get
out of there alive which I had my doubts
along the way and yeah so I saw a really
ugly side of myself on that trip and to
know that I'm capable of that as well as
the good stuff is pretty enlightening in
some way does it make you feel less
judgmental of others or does it like
deepen that reservoir of empathy for
other people
it definitely deepens the reservoir of
empathy and I've definitely had a lot of
pedestals that I stood on in my 20s and
30s and pretty much been knocked off of
all of those so humility empathy yeah
definitely I've learned to be less
judgmental and understand that everyone
has their own history that they're
bringing into a situation so yeah and I
mean the simplicity really is kind of
what you were talking about earlier like
just if we can just simplify our lives
you know we we so over complicate
everything
unnecessarily and it's interesting that
you go and you're so in touch with that
when you're on these expeditions and
that even you who's gone out and done
things you know the vast majority of
people will never ever do it wears off
when you come back it doesn't wears off
it's like ya can't stick why can't I
can't do yeah I mean I'm just as dick as
addicted to my Instagram feed or
whatever the next person but yet it
seems like what I love about being in
the mountains is like the phone is
nothing's ringing nothing's like India
they won't let you bring the Sat phone
but ya know the law there that's so
pretty they're working on changing it
but I did I got a nice like right I
snuck it in in 2013 fortunately cuz one
of our team members got pulmonary edema
and so we had to call in a rescue but
but you had to call like somebody in
Italy right
because you get arrested for having the
phone well I got arrested for having the
phone anyway yeah but they wouldn't
answer the phone because they can
recognize a Sat number so we had to call
through Italy and then Italy called
what's the deal with you know because
especially the reason we're in is very
close to there's a lot of drug smuggling
and they're just afraid of you know
terrorism and all that but there's
they're working on it there's definitely
ways to figure out how you can yeah yeah
yeah like they could register them
something yeah they register Emma you
rent them they have an international
amount or an Indian mountaineering
Federation there so you know give phones
to that Federation and then you rent
them from the mountaineering Federation
there's like you're working on it it
would be an easy fix but there's a lot
of red tape in India but back to that
that earlier point you know it's so
beautiful how you describe like being in
these communities and seeing the kids
and they're happy and they're living in
you know like they have nothing yeah and
and there's joy right
and so we intellectualized that and we
understand like oh those people are
happy and then you you go to you know
bakersfield and you're like yeah people
don't look as happy wherever it is
doesn't matter okay and but we're not
like going well I'm gonna sell
everything and like move and go live
with right Blee like romanticizing with
you I mean these kids have incredibly
hard it's it's hard lies and they don't
have long life expectancies and you know
they have they don't have health care
and I mean it's a heart it's it's a hard
life and I think we're not gonna go
backwards as a society to that degree
and hopefully you know the goal of
humanity is to uplift everyone out of
that poverty but we have to can we find
value in different things I think yeah
can we can we capture some aspect of
of you know where that joy is coming
from and bring it into our own lives and
we're not so good at that
no you know no we do like complicating
it us we have to an hour and a half we
had a few more minutes here so you're
speaking tonight speaking tonight
that's about Surma I know so I'm sort of
like wishing that I could have seen you
talk before yeah a little bit more color
into this when you get up and and you
deliver these presentations like you're
telling the stories but what is it that
you want people to walk away with like
what is the message that you're trying
to deliver I want people to I mean be
inspired on one level but also to
embrace risk-taking and failure which
sounds like too kind of depressing
things but like embrace these things
because I think it opens up your this
little box that we live in and it opens
up your ability to get to know yourself
and your true potential through taking
risks and through failing and I mean
basically that's what this whole
expedition this Burma talk is about is
we took a huge risk and we failed on
many levels but you know we also
succeeded because we're all still here
and yeah what is your metric for success
in failure and weight you know as still
I struggle with this word failure it's
like there's the attempt to you know
live and do something outside of your
comfort zone weight and that should be
celebrated no matter what the outcome
because you know upon your return
you're fortified with whatever you
learned you have the experience and then
there's you know whatever that
experience delivered to you in terms of
how you can you know live
more fulfilled live better made of more
of yourself to others yeah so what we
get hung up on this word failure so oh
well you guys didn't make it to those
summit you failed right right not one
single person has ever said that to me
no no they're all like what are you
talking about that wasn't a failure that
was amazing you know or like what an
adventure look at it as a failure do you
or do you I mean I did for a while
afterwards not so much because of
reaching not reaching the summit but
just because of how our team dynamics
just imploded on that Ridge and I felt
you know as you know I was supposed to
be the glue for this team and I think I
just learned a lot about how not to lead
how to lead how just the intricacies and
you know sort of difficulties and in the
end though I always go back to like damn
it we signed up for an adventure and
that's what we had so what is all this
about like that's what we got we got
what we wanted you know right back up in
life do you hear often or I've I've
heard off and you know this refrain that
there are no great female role models
it's like we're in the Kardashian
culture and as a father of two young
girls I take issue with that there are
amazing women role models all over the
place but we just don't do a very good
job of celebrating them or making sure
that they're in the spotlight because
there's people like yourself that are
you know doing amazing things everywhere
so how do you think about like your role
as as you know as a as a woman as a
female role model to you know young
girls as somebody you know that they can
look up to do you do you spend time
thinking about that or you're just doing
what you're doing I do more and more I
mean if you look up like female
explorers on the Great Wide Web yeah are
you the first Google person no you get
Dora the Explorer you know
come on like so I think it's so more and
more I really do think about what it
means to be a role model for young girls
and there are so many role models out
there and really it's just a matter of
you know I think in a lot of ways women
are so you can correct me if you don't
agree but somewhat superior storytellers
especially in terms of adventure because
we talk about it so differently than the
keepers of the whale story and I agree
with that
yeah it's especially when it comes to
like adventure and climbing and and in
that genre we I feel like women speak
about it very differently than men and
and have an incredibly different unique
perspective what's it eat all of that
well I mean just in us talking right now
and granted you're asking the questions
but we're not talking about the peak of
evil and climbing and standing on the
top and how many summits I've made and
this that another we're talking about
I'm care about those kids I know but we
you know it's just like you're talking
about these stories of of just more it
just was emotional what does it mean
what it what is the point and I think
you're seeing the sprouting up of a lot
of female adventure writers as well as
adventurous and I think that through
speaking for me I can affect girls and
their idea of what it means to be a
woman in the workplace a woman an
adventure role model what what it means
to you know occupy a space that is
typically male-dominated and how how to
how to still take on that space but be a
woman and be a female
understand that there's huge value in
that because of the different
perspective you have and yeah I guess
that answer your question no no I mean
that's that's the heart of it yeah
that's the heart of it and it you know
it's we're talking about the perils of
the modern world and you know like I
said I have two daughters it's like I
see the influences and as much as you
try to guide and and and you know kind
of like insulate them from some of that
it's impossible right it's there it is
you know it is omnipresence no culture
and you have to work to kind of get
outside of that right so and I think
like you can do that with like even the
companies I work with mmm that North
Face for example you know they need to
be able to represent their female
athletes in the same way and with the
same push as the males and they're
working really hard at doing that and I
think that's how you get female role
models out there
so that when you hit explore you don't
get Dora you get Lynn Hill and you get
angel Collinson and Margo and you know
Ashima and all you know all of these
young women out there doing incredible
things and I pay attention more than
most people and I don't know who those
people are man I feel and I feel guilty
like I should right right yeah so
they're just climbers and ski you know
it's for well we gotta wrap this up but
that was awesome how do you feel
can we do it what are we not talking
about very inspiring thank you thank you
thank you for coming but all's but more
than that like thank you for what you do
thank you for you know being this
example and and I just want more people
to hear your voice and yeah are you
doing what you're doing do you have a
sense of what your next adventure may be
or
that percolating yeah no I I'm going to
spend a few weeks with Jim Morrison my
partner in life and all things and
decent climbing in the Sierras sort of
as a training platform for going back up
to the Arctic National Wildlife Refuge
it's one of like my favourite places on
this entire planet I've never been
anywhere like it and as you know there's
a lot of political and environmental
stuff going on up there so I'm gonna
spend a couple weeks up there with
another athlete kit DeLaurier at the end
of April and explore and sort of
document what a beautiful unique place
it is in hopes of influencing some
policy that's the next podcast yeah get
into that yeah
well that's very cool and you're kind of
on this this speaking to were yeah sorts
at the moment I mean the theater you're
speaking out it's a thousand of civil
civics if it's a beautiful theatre yeah
it's been the coolest part of touring is
yeah yeah so how many do you have more
cities coming up like I'm kind of done
for the season I just have one more at
the Mesa Arts Center I think in Mesa
Arizona Phoenix yeah cool
I've been in that theater - yes really
good theaters the Seattle Theatre the
vanaroja was in there that was a really
good theater someone in Kansas City was
incredible there's some good ones Pro
Theatre in Dallas it's like yeah yeah
they have this national geographic' live
series so different cities hosts
anywhere from three to five shows in a
season and you can you buy like seasons
passes for it it's pretty cool it's cool
usually do it in the winter you know
when it's dark and cold and people can
go listen to good stories awesome yeah
well good luck tonight thank you and
good luck good luck to you in life in
general I think same to you
alright so people wanna
want to connect with Hillary first of
all final question is it still Hillary
O'Neil or is it Tory Nelson Hillary
Nelson Nelson well okay I'm glad I asked
you know but it's transitioning so
you're like Hillary O'Neal on Twitter
and yeah I could tell it like your
website's hilaree nelson oh wow some
kind of hilaree nelson o'neal but it's
transitioning to hillary no I got yeah
cool um my maiden name from me
right I'm divorced yeah
all right well cool um after your next
expedition come back and talk to me
about it's more me okay all right cool
good thanks thank you thank you thank
you
[Music]